okay there is a place where you can
discuss newsworthy items discussed on
the program and those not covered on the
program with other david pakman show
viewers nearly 10,000 people are now
subscribed to the David Pakman show
subreddit which you can find at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t we didn't
cover this story but it was mentioned on
the subreddit so i'll bring it up now
there was a very strange development
where this trump troll jacob wall who
was previously wrapped up in trying to
generate false sexual assault claims
against robert muller has been caught
trying to concoct bogus sexual assault
claims against pete Budaj edge and the
first commenter their ass why won't this
dude go away meaning jacob wall and I
completely concur with that sentiment
and more importantly is he ever going to
face consequences and actually have to
maybe go to prison or jail for the stuff
that he's doing because there is a
significant amount of extraordinarily
improper behavior here some of which may
actually rise to the level of
criminality and of course tainted in all
of this like Pete Budaj
is a gay guy and wrapped up in trying to
concoct sexual assault allegations
against him is this implicit smear that
is often levied by the homophobic right
against gay men of them being pedophiles
or assaulters when in reality they're
just attracted to men that that's it and
jacob wall diving headfirst into that so
notable story want to acknowledge it
although we're not going to be covering
it into too much detail on the show also
from the david pakman show subreddit i
spotted a a post in response to my
livestream with stephen destiny bonel
from a couple of days ago asking can we
get david and destiny drums keyboard
single during their next show together
yes so people noticed that last week
when i was broadcasting remotely i had
an electronic drum set behind me and
destiny during our live stream had a
keyboard piano digital piano Alec
chronic piano I don't know what they're
called at this point behind him and what
about the idea of us doing some kind of
musical collaboration and I'm game if
people want to contact destiny and tell
them that we should do this I'm glad to
do it it could be done live I mean we
could say eff it we'll do it live I'll
just I'll write it and we'll do it live
that's one possibility
the other possibility is that we record
our parts separately and or something
like that but I'm completely up for a
music collaboration with destiny
join the discussion as nearly 10,000 of
you already have david pakman.com slash
re d di t